bonjour Céline vous voulez c'est renier
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être notre
invité ce matin pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de Paris
rattaché au groupe les républicains et
vice-présidents du groupe d'amitié
France Royaume-Uni on va bien sûr
longuement parler du couronnement de
Charles III dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui était donc en
Charente-Maritime hier à Saintes il a
présenté sa réforme du lycée
professionnel accueilli une fois de plus
par un concert de casserole est-ce que
vous déplorez oui parce que il faut
toujours discuter on est en démocratie
j'ai été interpellé par une dame encore
très récemment devant le Sénat hier qui
me disait madame on est plus en
démocratie j'ai dit on n'est pas non
plus dans un pays totalitaire on a un
parlement on discute non moi les
casseroles ça me alors douloureusement
un paradoxalement ça me fait penser à
cet épisode pendant
le covid ou justement on faisait
tambouriner les casseroles pour
remercier tous ces métiers qui faisaient
les communomies de guerre à l'époque et
qui étaient indispensable maintenant
c'est un tout autre contexte mais je
pense que la CGT devrait admettre que
maintenant on est passé dans l'air post
réforme des retraites et qu'il faut
arrêter et en tout cas apparaît les
manifestations arrêter
les concerts de casseroles ça veut dire
que de toute évidence il ne souhaite pas
discuter alors je reconnais les torts de
Macron dans cette affaire bien
évidemment lesquels la méthode mais sur
la méthode bien entendu à ses verticale
vous savez on est à l'air des réseaux
sociaux et aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
prendre une décision verticale qui vient
du politique d'en haut même si c'est le
politique qui à base des discussions au
Parlement doit trancher il doit
co-construire les décisions dans le pays
avec la population il ne l'a pas assez
fait d'ailleurs après le grand débat
maintenant on a les petits débats et
vous vous souvenez Giscard qui
s'invitait dans les foyers des Français
pour déjeuner maintenant on a Macron à
la cantoche bon la vue hier avec les
étudiants c'est je dirais plutôt une
bonne chose mais elle accueillir des
concerts de casseroles c'est plutôt de
l'ordre de l'anecdote et ça empêche
toute discussion c'est dommage comment
on sort de ce blocage justement le rip à
une nouvelle fois le référendum a une
nouvelle fois été rejeté par le Conseil
constitutionnel vous dites à la CGT il
faut arrêter de il faut tourner la page
vous dites aussi ça aux opposants en
fait l'Inter syndicale on voit bien
maintenant elle est relativement
divisée ou en tout cas elle est plus
aussi unique il y a quelques semaines
puisque la CFDT Laurent Berger disait
encore qu'il était prêt à discuter avec
le gouvernement donc on voit bien
maintenant qu'il y a une division sur ce
front cela veut dire qu'on passe
peut-être à autre chose d'ailleurs c'est
souhaitable Macron d'ailleurs et ses
ministres font en sorte que voilà le
débat se disperse autour de différents
sujets maintenant c'est qu'il a annoncé
à Saint-Hilaire sur la réforme de
l'enseignement professionnel et plutôt
une bonne chose un milliard d'euros une
gratification de stage pardon pour les
laisser un surnomènes mesures voilà
Monsieur de bonnes mesures pour les
lycéens bien évidemment l'enseignement
professionnel c'est une voix d'avenir
qui est souvent mal considérée qui a
mauvaise réputation
rapprocher les jeunes de l'entreprise
c'est une bonne chose
il y a un sujet dont on n'a pas assez
parlé dans la campagne présidentielle et
dont on ne parle pas assez dans le débat
public je le déplore et on devrait pas
en parler dans les partis politiques
c'est l'émergence de l'intelligence
artificielle logiciel je dis ça parce
que il va falloir créer les métiers de
demain au détriment avec l'émergence de
l'intelligence artificielle il y a des
métiers qui vont disparaître qui seront
entre autres robotisés donc il faut
favoriser dans la jeune génération des
métiers qui auront de l'avenir et des
métiers à base de ce qu'on peut
confectionner avec la main par exemple
avec le cerveau avec le cœur on en parle
de manière quasiment philosophique et
donc cette cette
dispositifs autour de la formation
professionnelle ils sont importants 30%
des étudiants d'ailleurs qui sortent de
formation professionnelle ne trouvent
pas d'emploi aujourd'hui donc il faut le
réformer après un milliard c'est
toujours encore de l'argent insufflé au
moment les républicains alerte sur la
dépense publique c'est pas le bon moment
pour vous et encore une fois on a besoin
de réformes et non pas de maître de
l'argent de manière incessante et on a
l'impression que chaque fois quand même
Emmanuel Macron répond à une crise par
un peu plus d'argent public c'est
dommage on va parler de l'actualité dans
nos régions on va aller du côté de Gien
dans le Loiret où on retrouve Alexis
Marie bonjour Alexis merci d'être avec
nous journalistes à la République du
Centre et Alexis vous allez nous parler
pouvoir d'achat et inflation l'inflation
qui touche notamment les boulangers
alors sont-ils enfin sortis de la crise
a priori c'est encore un peu tôt pour le
dire en tout cas on est retourné voir un
certain nombre de d'artisans qu'on avait
rencontré en janvier lorsque la crise du
coût des matières premières et de
l'énergie était au plus fort là quelques
mois après c'est vrai que le son de
cloche n'est pas uneanime il faut
trouver des solutions pour ces pour ces
artisans des habitudes de fabrication
ont été modifiées certains attendent les
effets du bouclier tarifaire par rapport
à leur facture d'électricité ne savent
pas trop sur sur quel pied danser et
puis certains surtout font attention à
tout aujourd'hui vraiment on a moins de
économie et traquer pour réussir à faire
du chiffre d'affaires mais surtout à
dégager une marge suffisante pour vivre
de de son activité et donc Madame la
signature je voulais vous demander
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a eu
suffisamment de mesure prises afin
d'accompagner ces boulangers pour faire
face à la coup du au coût de une matière
première et l'inflation par rapport
laflation et donc le coût de l'énergie
également oui au fait référence au
bouclier du gaz et puis d'électricité
c'était une mesure d'urgence qu'il
fallait prendre bien évidemment puisque
on avait vu que c'est fameux boulangers
mais les boulangers on parle les
boulangers on pourrait parler de tout ce
qui est petit commerçant commerce de
proximité qui sont au combien important
dans les villes et pour les habitants et
pour assurer un maillage de commerçants
très important on a bien vu que leurs
factures d'électricité il y a quelques
mois passé du simple au double trip voir
multiplier par 10 et qui ne pouvait plus
s'en sortir et que beaucoup étaient
menacés de mettre la clé sous la porte
alors bien évidemment le gouvernement
nous les élus locaux la chambre des
territoires nous avons été derrière eux
et il était très important de mettre ce
bouclier en place alors je crois que le
bouclier sur le gaz va être supprimé
puisque on est revenu au prix d'avant
crise mais tout ce qui peut être de
nature à aider est une bonne chose bien
évidemment parce que parce que parce que
ils n'ont pas beaucoup de trésorerie et
que ils sont souvent difficultés et que
c'est une conjonction de facteurs
effectivement avec une hausse des
matières premières de manière générale
mais il faut continuer ces aides parce
qu'on en revient à la question de la
dépense publique on en revient à la
question de la dépense publique non non
le gaz donc ça va être supprimé je crois
au mois de juillet l'électricité il faut
continuer parce que de tout évident
s'ils ne pourront pas s'en sortir non
plus et c'est pas la peine de voir des
commerces auquel on est attaché fermé ça
veut dire du chômage et ça veut dire
aussi que on est dans des déserts aussi
dans certaines villes où les commerces
de proximité jouent un rôle même social
qui est très important donc de toute
évidence il faut quand même être
derrière eux c'est toujours la dépense
publique bien sûr mais la dépense
publique elle doit être décidée et
arbitrer à bon escient sur les bons sur
les bons arbitrages quoi j'allais dire
et là pour nous ça en est un
Alexis on va parler d'un autre sujet
puisque du côté d'Orléans ce sont les
fêtes joanniques les fêtes de Jeanne
d'Arc
tout à fait alors c'est vrai que là il y
a le couronnement de Charles III qui va
se dérouler et qui va donc occuper
l'actualité mais Orléans c'est aussi
enfin du moins c'est sous ce souvenir de
la victoire de Jeanne d'Arc face aux
Anglais le 8 mai 1429 les pas question
de de recréer un quelconque antagoniste
entre France et anglais ce matin mais
force est de constater que ce weekend la
ville d'Orléans va vivre au rythme de
Jeanne d'Arc et de la libération de la
ville et donc du coup depuis un certain
nombre d'années c'est commémoration
attire beaucoup de beaucoup de monde à
Orléans il y a il y a il y a un certain
nombre d'événements donc le avec ce
week-end pas mal de choses en
particulier
la vitesse d'honneur c'est une une
Iranienne qui sera là cette année pour
prêcher la bonne parole il y aura
également un set électron enfin il y a
vraiment beaucoup de choses et Jeanne
d'Arc est au centre de toutes ces
animations et donc Madame laissez notre
fils moi je vous demander est-ce que
vous estimez qu'il faille toujours se
justifier lorsque vous évoquez Jeanne
d'Arc parce que effectivement il y a une
certaine récupération de la classe
politique plutôt extrême droite qui qui
s'en en parle de cette héroïne est-ce
que est-ce que pour vous c'est Jeanne
d'Arc est au-dessus de ses contingences
politiques
Jeanne d'Arc est bien entendu largement
au-dessus de cette contingence politique
on a vu que l'histoire qui était life à
la manière dont l'histoire de Jeanne
d'Arc avait été
avait été restitué au fil des siècles
avait varié et on peut regretter
qu'effectivement
le symbole de Jeanne d'Arc qui est
devenu notamment à la fin du 19e siècle
grâce à Jules Michelet
un symbole vraiment mythique était pris
à son compte par notamment le
rassemblement national ce qui fait que
ça a été une figure quand on a moins
parlé ces dernières années pour autant
c'est la sainte patronne de résistance
d'une certaine forme de nationalisme
aussi c'est-à-dire que on protège la
France avant tout au détriment de son
propre destin c'est un personnage qui
est éminemment romanesque et qui
appartient à tout le monde et à personne
et personne ne devrait préempter cette
incarnation de la France dont on aurait
peut-être beaucoup besoin aujourd'hui en
terme de symbole donc je vous souhaite
de belles fêtes et je trouve que sont
belles idées et le fait d'avoir pris une
Iranienne aussi pour incarner cette fête
c'est un symbole qui est très très
important j'ai participé récemment un
colloque sur le combat pour les femmes
iraniennes l'actualité autour des
retraites à éclipser ce problème
international qui est gravissime ce sont
des femmes qui se battent pour leur
liberté et je trouve que le parallèle
que vous avez fait avec ce qui incarne
Jeanne d'Arc est un très beau parallèle
et un très beau symbole et je vous
souhaite vraiment plein de réussite dans
cet événement
et cette année Alexis Marie s'est faite
joannique sont à la haine de la
République du Centre en plein Moyen-Âge
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Alexis d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin depuis le Loiret bonne journée à
vous Alexis on va pas parler de quelques
questions politiques des sénatoriales
avant de parler de Charles III
sénatorial qui auront lieu le 24
septembre à Paris fait partie des zones
renouvelables est-ce que vous serez
candidate si vous voulez l'expérience je
me suis occupé de sujet
à mon sens important et je l'ai fait
avec beaucoup de coeur et d'engagement
j'ai fait un rapport sur la délinquance
des mineurs je me suis engagée sur des
sujets comme le harcèlement et le
cyber-harcèlement qui est un sujet qui
est très important il y a eu des sujets
autour de la jeunesse
en matière de culture plus récemment on
a fait un rapport très important ce
cinéma qu'on va présenter le 24 mai donc
évidemment j'ai envie de poursuivre cet
engagement pour répondre à votre
question parce que ce serait des
dossiers qu'il faut suivre dans les dans
les prochaines années vous serez
candidate on sait que les la est divisée
à Paris vous serez candidate je vous
espérez une liste commune où vous serez
candidate sur une liste à part est-ce
que vous aurez votre propre liste alors
moi j'ai toujours été une femme d'union
femme d'engagement une femme de
conviction je regrette d'être
partiellement maintenant parce que j'ai
pris quelques distances et pour cause
dans un parti où on pense plutôt souvent
à exclure plutôt qu'à donner envie aux
gens de rester et certainement jamais à
comprendre pourquoi certaines
personnalités politiques ont quitté la
famille politique je le regrette donc
Xavier Bertrand et d'autres au moment où
ceux qui sont devenus les ministres de
Macron aujourd'hui ont quitté le parti
personne a essayé de les retenir
personne n'a essayé de savoir et de
comprendre pourquoi ils étaient partis
et on en est là où on en est aujourd'hui
malheureusement la division règne au
sein du parti on ne va pas se mentir
c'est lié aussi à nos résultats
électoraux désastreux mais c'est un peu
un cercle vicieux c'est à dire que comme
vous avez des résultats électoraux
désastreux et bien il y a une crise
passion toujours autour des mêmes sauf
que à partir du moment certaines un
certain nombre de personnes à emmener le
parti là où il est aujourd'hui il faut
se poser la question du renouvellement
qui sont ces personnes ah mais vous les
connaissez aussi bien que moi moi je ne
fais pas de nain droping mais en ce que
je veux dire c'est que dans une
entreprise quand ça n'a pas fonctionné
ou changer un certain nombre de
personnes vous changez la doctrine et
puis vous essayez d'avoir une vision
aujourd'hui là vous avez changé de
président
on voit qu'il y a quand même un problème
de leadership et personnellement moi
j'essaie de le joindre plusieurs fois de
manière à ce qu'on puisse discuter
j'attends encore qui reviennent vers moi
je suis parlementaire de Paris rattaché
au groupe et l'air j'aurais aimé quand
même pouvoir discuter avec lui donc je
ne critique personne je ne jette la
pierre à personne mais il y a un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements sur
lesquels il faudrait revenir et à Paris
évidemment tout le monde est divisé et
ça fait belle lurette qu'à Paris on sait
toujours attaché à ce qui est pas une
personnalité qui émerge pour pouvoir
regagner la capitale il serait quand
même temps mais j'ai quand même très
peur pour l'avenir donc vous ferez votre
liste probablement et vous pensez que la
droite les divisions de la droite à
Paris vont lui faire perdre des sièges
il y a 4 sénateurs toujours fait perdre
à l'heure actuelle de droite les
divisions toujours fait perdre des
sièges à Paris et c'est les Parisiens
qui en sont les premières victimes et
quand on voit l'état de Paris
aujourd'hui on ne peut s'en contenter on
n'a pas les moyens de nos divisions mais
les divisions continuent il y a une
liste qui circule elle ne contente
personne et pour cause bon donc chacun
prendra ses responsabilités
qui ont perdu plusieurs fois les
élections sur leur nom et qui trouve le
moyen de se recaser au Sénat et puis
vous avez des personnes qui manquent de
courage et qui devraient montrer
l'exemple aux militants à d'autres élus
dans des combats politiques qui n'osent
pas les assumer qui se disent
planquons-nous en estimant que le Sénat
c'est une plante en fait le Sénat ça
n'est pas une plante c'est le camp de
base pour la droite aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'un carnet un certain nombre de
dossiers de les défendre et moi je
déplore tout ça personnellement on va
parler de Charles III vous êtes précisé
vous êtes vice-président du groupe
d'amitié France réunis et vous suivez
l'actualité oui de la famille royale
britannique on commence notre page
spéciale consacrée à ce couronnement
entre Charles III qui aura donc lieu
demain en tant qu'amet va nous rejoindre
il va tout nous dire de la cérémonie
[Musique]
[Rires]
effectivement elle a cérémonie doit
débuter vers midi demain Charles III et
son épouse Kamila Parker bows la reine
qu'on sort comme on dit ils vont quitter
ce palais de Buckingham ce sera vers
11h20 à bord d'un immense carrosse
tractée par 6 chevaux escortés par 200
membres des forces armées d'ailleurs on
a vu des répétitions de nuit c'était il
y a deux jours on voit un carrosse voilà
qui quitte le palais sous bonne garde
avec 200 membres de forces armées des
dizaines de fautes golds ce sont ces
soldats de la garde royale qui portent
des bonnets à poils d'ours des centaines
de milliers de personnes devraient être
disposées tout autour de ce parcours
pour vivre ce moment historique les rues
de Londres sont également parées du
drapeau du pays l'Union Jack avec
également vous le voyez au milieu la
bannière spéciale de la coronation le
couronnement et on a vu aussi un des
boutiques spéciales avec des goodies
marqués de cet événement c'était en
vente dans les boutiques de la ville la
cérémonie en elle-même va durer deux
heures à l'abbaye de Westminster en
présence de 2000 invités triées sur le
volet de dont toutes les têtes
couronnées d'Europe roi d'Espagne roi de
Suède ou encore couple princier japonais
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui représentera
la France avec son épouse Brigitte il y
a des questions qui se posent sur le
coup de cette cérémonie combien
va-t-elle coûter Quentin alors le coût
de l'événement n'a pas été révélé mais
il est estimé par la braise par la
presse britannique entre 50 et 100
millions de livres sterling soit vous le
voyez 57 à 114 millions d'euros c'est
sans prendre en compte le coût de la
sécurité de l'événement alors tout cela
est largement financé par les
contribuables britanniques nous cette
question c'est un événement historique
et un événement majeur c'est une boule
espérreniers qu'est-ce qui symbolise à
vos yeux on ira sur le coup un peu après
mais qu'est-ce qu'il symbolise pour vous
oui je veux bien revenir sur d'un coup
il symbolise que le monde entier va
avoir les yeux rivés sur l'Angleterre
malgré tout c'est une monarchie qui est
unique au monde c'est du soft power on
verra sur le coup parce qu'il est très
important mais le roi le roi Charles les
couronné dans une Angleterre qui en
proie beaucoup de difficultés
économiques il ne peut pas les ignorer
donc il doit agir dans la continuité par
rapport à sa mère qui était adorée parce
que il y a beaucoup de Britanniques et
notamment 12% des jeunes Britanniques
qui disent plus du tout s'intéresser à
cet événement mais enfin quand on
regarde les sondages 80% des
Britanniques ont une excellente opinion
de la reine lui en a une un peu moins
bonne mais néanmoins ça faisait dix ans
qu'il y avait pas eu ce couronnement
c'est un événement majeur ce qu'il doit
faire c'est éblouir sans offenser tout
en rassemblant le peuple britannique
c'est ça le défi qu'il a aujourd'hui
152 en ayant réduit la voilure parce que
l'Angleterre il y a 10 % d'inflation
vous avez 21 % de la population qui vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté alors
justement allons sur ce vous avez 25
millions de personnes qui sont quand
même à l'aide alimentaire justement
c'est une politique d'austérité donc
évidemment il ne peut pas y avoir trop
de faces certains britanniques eux-mêmes
parlent de gabgie lorsqu'on les
interroge dans le dans les reportages
qu'est-ce que vous cette estimation du
coût de la cérémonie ça vous évoque face
à justement cette crise économique que
traverse en Bretagne la monarchie c'est
1 euro 12 par britannique bon donc c'est
quand même pas énorme évidemment c'est
toujours ça de manière générale dans le
monde il est de bon temps de constater
de contester les institutions donc
évidemment l'Angleterre ne veut la
Grande-Bretagne
échappe pas bien évidemment
vous avez dit que c'était des coûts
entre 50 millions et 100 millions à peu
près mais ça va rapporter un milliard
quatre c'est quand même important et
puis du point de vue d'être diplomatie
c'est du soft power très important quand
même je vous dis le monde entier aura
les yeux rivés sur les mais il a
conscience de ces réalités le roi
Charles parce que il s'investit
énormément avec ce qui est maintenant la
reine qu'on sort la reine Kamilya dans
des associations caritatives il a
conscience que la monarchie est assez
est assez mal vu par les jeunes donc il
a invité de nombreux jeunes à la
cérémonie là où il devait y avoir
normalement un hommage des pères qui
s'est traditionnellement c'est une
tradition millénaire il va faire un
hommage de la population voilà donc je
pense qu'il est quand même connecté en
réalité de l'Angleterre qui est vraiment
en proie des difficultés majeures et il
doit mettre en avant on a vu hier ces
images de William et Kate dans un pub
anglais prendre le métro il doit aussi
mettre en avant William et Kate pour
justement montrer que l'avenir de la
monarchie est là mais absolument que
l'avenir de la monarchie est là la
famille royale a été en proie quand même
à des difficultés familiales
difficile on va pas pleurer bien entendu
mais enfin bon on adore tout ça quand
même on aime bien regarder suivre ça le
feuilleton il y a eu Lady Diana il y a
eu tout ça
et puis peut-être enfin il y a des
Britanniques qui disent que ça les
change de leur quotidien aussi que d'une
certaine manière une espèce de
schizophrénie par rapport à tout ça mais
quand vous voyez Londres pleine de
drapeaux dans les petites villes
anglaises etc c'est quand même assez
sympa et puis c'est quand même un
événement qui est très important puis
qui comme on disait pas si couteau que
ça a qui rapporte email Macron et
Brigitte Macron seront présents on l'a
dit dans l'abbaye de l'Ouest Minster a
placé dans le coin des poètes c'est à
dire le 37 sud de l'abbaye c'est très
précis tout est bien entendu très
minutieusement planifié à l'avance mais
on a lu que c'était plutôt bien placé
finalement la France a été choyée dans
le dans l'endroit où il sera placé la
France on le dit c'est une République
c'est un peu une choc un choc des
cultures entre entre nous et la perfida
le burnant on n'a pas toujours été un
peu nostalgique de notre roi
j'ai l'impression mais c'est vrai que
nos relations n'ont pas toujours été
simples depuis très longtemps on se
réjouissait à l'idée que le roi Charles
Vienne même au Sénat au mois de mars on
a déploré les raisons pour lesquelles il
est pas venu la première visite à
l'étranger dans le pays la France pour
sa première visite d'État ce qui était
tout un symbole parce qu'on avait eu des
des difficultés avec les quotas de pêche
au moment du brexit avec
le problème de des migrants il y a eu un
accord qui a été trouvé au mois de
novembre donc nos relations pas toujours
été simple donc il a montré vraiment une
envie de faire un pas envers la France
on l'a dit du groupe d'amitié François
Royaume-Uni ça va laisser des traces
cette visite annulée à 48 heures de
l'événement fin mars bah oui c'est la
fiche mal c'est vous me permettez
l'expression un peu très bien là pour à
Paris rempli de poubelles des des camps
un peu partout mais mais il va revenir
je pense qu'il va reprogrammer cette
visite non non c'était un raté
diplomatique de toute évidence pour les
relations entre de pays mais oui il va
revenir et puis je pense que ce sera un
meilleur contexte mais c'est ton jamais
vous parlez de soft power il y a
plusieurs têtes qu'on est Quentin l'a
dit plusieurs chefs d'État évidemment
qui seront présents la cérémonie sera
diffusée dans le monde entier c'est
aussi un enjeu diplomatique fort pour le
Royaume-Uni ce qu'on rendement c'est un
enjeu diplomatique très fort n'oubliez
pas aussi qu'il est à la tête de 14 pays
du commonwears donc ce n'est plus la
Grande-Bretagne de l'époque mais
rappelez-vous quand même le côté
iconique tellement apprécié de cette
reine Elisabeth II qui savait dire les
choses sans les dire je ne sais pas s'il
pourrait être autant dans le neveu comme
planning never explain on est à l'heure
des réseaux sociaux il va devoir faire
preuve de modernité mais ce qui va faire
subsister non mais la monnaie quand on
monte sur le trône à 74 ans ce qui va
faire voilà subsister à la monarchie à
l'avenir ça va être justement de voir
être neutre et rester au dessus de tout
ça et vous avez même en politique même
politique française et mondiale dès
qu'on ne parle pas déjà on jouit d'une
aura et on arrive à paradoxalement faire
passer plus de messages la bonne hernie
je vous dis par exemple dans la manière
dont il a organisé les célébrations en
réduisant la voilure en ayant moins de
monde en faisant faire le match par la
population en mettant tous les cultes ça
c'est une preuve de modernité et puis la
modernité c'est de dire on va réduire le
nombre de la famille le nom le nombre
demande de la famille royale qui
travaille qui bénéficie de subventions
etc parce ce genre de choses quoi mais
il est quand même très contesté auprès
de certains britanniques qui disent nous
on est dans la panade et lui voilà il
nous fait payer des taxes etc autour
d'un film je vous dis c'est un euro 12
donc vous êtes inquiète quand même pour
pour l'avenir de la monarchie
britannique où selon vous elle a encore
de beaux jours devant elle selon moi
elle a encore de beaux jours devant elle
mais la preuve et puis en plus ils
savent organiser comme vous disiez
c'était millimétré vous souvenez le
jubilé de la reine la manière dont les
funérailles ont été organisés en
parallèle avec ce qui s'était passé au
Stade de France nous on a pu quand même
la différence et c'est de la diplomatie
purement britannique c'est voilà c'est
important nous on a le luxe on a tout ça
eux ils ont leur monarchie ils y sont
attachésite facteurs de cohésion malgré
tout justement vous avez évoqué les
jeunes qui croient de moins en moins
notamment les très jeunes il y a une
étude effectivement qui est sortie sur
ce thème notamment à cause des derniers
épisodes du feuilleton avec Harry et son
épouse Megane qui ont quitté la
Grande-Bretagne pour aller rejoindre la
Californie eux ils ont presque fait un
business de ce feuilleton en vendant des
livres en vendant des chroniques sur sur
Spotify il y a une dérive qui est
possible aussi dans l'avenir avec cette
famille royale non non mais il y a
toujours une dérive on a vu que il y
avait des difficultés innombrables
depuis des années rappelez-vous Lady
Diana qui avait fait ses interviews qui
bon voilà la reine Kamila aujourd'hui
qui était déjà qui interférait avec ce
couple et et vous voyez à quel point il
y a une résilience quand même parce que
Diana était adulée par le monde entier
rappelez-vous quand elle est décédée à
Paris 31 août et c'est dommages
nationaux il y a une sidération
planétaire autour de Lady Dana et
pourtant la reine Kamila est aujourd'hui
la reine qu'on sort la reine Elizabeth
II a fait elle-même preuve de modernité
en la nommant Rennes qu'on sort parce
que aujourd'hui c'est un couple qui est
couronné qui est sacrée donc il y a
quand même une faculté d'adaptation
voilà de toute façon de là dépend leur
survie il y a pas mais c'est une
spécificité mondiale vous serez devant
votre télé demain bien évidemment
[Rires]
le parlementaire exactement on va parler
de la réforme des retraites de la
proposition de loi du groupe liote qui
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale au début
du mois de juin
Dra sur Charente-Maritime quelle est
l'avenir de la contestation contre la
réforme des retraites on en parle merci
beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité on continue
notre page spéciale Charles III c'est
Jean descart qui nous rejoint maintenant